inside great performance is innovation
and design you see it on the field and
guys like von Miller you see it on the
sidelines and you see it in the design
of great stadiums this is the design of
the game with your keys to a great
performance what helped me the most is
just losing myself in my crowd I want to
be great everybody that's involved in my
life I want to make those guys proud I i
did not get here by myself by any means
you know we want a superbug confetti
falling some of the brother come out and
I saw my mom come out and my dad come
out and face it they had it was just it
was just magical football specifically
at such a physically demanding and
emotionally demanding game that as a
reporter I need to respond as quickly as
possible to the news I've got about a
30-second window if I don't get it out
someone's gonna beat me to it how is the
new mercedes-benz Stadium
revolutionising the fan experience
before we ever broke ground we started
with an intention to reimagine each and
every aspect of what we believe matters
to the fam the details are what makes
the difference between a world-class
company a world-class operation a
world-class customer experience and
those that are just average let's be
honest most of the guys in the NFL have
crappy style right I'm saying you know
like they got bad game you've got a
really good game so how would you
describe your style a lot of my stuff is
just independent on myself if I like it
on my gear yeah it's so hard to be
yourself in 2016 it's so hard to be
yourself in his daily so when you
actually achieve them you accomplish
that this unique is only one of you so I
feel like I've been able to do I'm
getting
idea when I'm at mercedes-benz stadium
design and innovation are going to be
pretty crucial I think the most
innovative parts of the stadium include
our state-of-the-art retractable roof
first of its kind the halo board our
64,000 square feet of the LED it all
matters it's all part of a holistic
system with a fan in the middle talk to
me a little bit about the innovations
that you feel you've brought to your
line of work one thing that's been
fantastic is social media has allowed me
to cook for a public-facing persona that
allows people to build trust with me
without me even knowing it do you see a
link between style and performance
what's definitely I think you look good
player that's like V you know Santa but
I think being consistent every single
day when you don't feel like putting on
any any type of jeans or any type of
style I think heaven it just creates a
lifestyle and um knows of the ideal
moments where it's direct correlation to
performance and fashion